i've actually been spending my pandemic  down here in florida i did my quarantine  here which was pretty amazing because  fifty percent of the people in florida  believe in cobit and the other fifty  percent will have you spin their mouth  to prove they're not gay  yeah i went through a little bit of a  covet breakup we did what's called a  conscious uncoupling that's when you  break up but you still have six months  left on that lease  alcohol will give you confidence and i  know that for a fact because one time  when i was drunk i invited a woman back  to my apartment when i knew i didn't  have electricity  she came too or she didn't come but she  like showed up and then left  [Applause]